hey guys i'm ryan right and elicit me
crazy so we're gonna start off our night
with watching some vines I like funny
yeah I like vines too wait what kind of
finds fell like the funny vines are like
the really weird depressing ones we're
animal vines cuz those are fun yeah I
wish we went with the really depressing
ones cuz that would have thrown
beautiful off fortunately got funny ones
you know what I thought
shrek is love shrek his life was gonna
be funny but no I was very very wrong
sigh I feel like I don't know you
anymore
that shit's hilarious nothing like Shrek
rape you haven't seen the video I kinda
ruined it for it
if this emoji could talk it would say I
volunteer as tribute
hey Roger Potter get what need you
really yo you you got your pocket hey
everything is good we're about to make
some pancakes
we go jelly yeah holy [ __ ] there's a
spider mister where what the [ __ ]
spire where's the [ __ ] spider what
spider I want a tattoo what should I get
just get something it means a lot to you
first things first
that's the pressure six-year-old my car
just found out she's pregnant
wait MTV still doing a show like I'm
gonna be on it wait my boobs can get
bigger I'm gonna go on a BA doli spoiler
I'm trying to stance a Glock how much
time what's second this is a fine I'm
gonna [ __ ] with my friend Kenny dude
have fun
well yeah don't you ever touch me like
that again done I think he's my favorite
yes he he who's ready [ __ ] Oh surprise
surprise [ __ ] popcorn again we're
gonna get some [ __ ] wings up in your
daughter
Wow really is some kind of window to the
soul ran outside and and I'm wearing my
Jays what's your big fin blunt survival
tip simply take your headphones place
them in your pocket pull them out
instant fish net hey mom mom fatherly
advice play with the child or sound as a
lion mate yeah okay buddy I get up I get
up no okay
lag money all day every day like [ __ ]
cute o swag money up oh we can't be
friends all day every day
damn my eye itches
I'm Debbie blading is about breathing in
through the buzz on and out the caboose
no play don't even acknowledge that they
exist because that's just a waste of
time we've known each other for a while
now is it okay if I call you my new
friend oh my god what is wrong with you
never a girl oh [ __ ] ah tonight
oh my you Stephanie the kids after you
that's again Jason I'm getting married
how is it for you the best thing I ever
did see I can't wait to have that right
honey yes Oh is the most beautiful thing
I've ever seen in my life
it's watermelone it's not a water ballon
magic you destroy binds give to any
woman's heart
sure goodbye Nana she'll love you
forever
it is true because like mine can
represent your sense of humor and then
she laughs and you laugh you guys both
have a moment you have a moment together
you know he shared something he liked
that she liked it too it's a moment
beautiful the one who catches his eye
it's a yeah it's awesome time every time
thanks for telling us to do though I
needed this doesn't I yeah I needed this
today I like it because if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe here and
you can subscribe to Alyssa's channel
China for China like it
Alyssa's channel Alyssa be crazy
where
she is out of [ __ ] control election
she does the craziest things
she digs graves up she electrocuted a
dog I won't never electric our doubt
that chinchilla she has that she loves
so much she for some reason electrocutes
her dog on the channel after she digs up
the bodies from the grave she's [ __ ]
crazy she has sex with the dead bodies
what is wrong with you
that's where does your mind go promoting
your channel I'm gonna sell the title
come on
but that concerns me that he went there
why it was your life not mine
you're [ __ ] weird you know what do
you know do you know what time it is
it's time to check your watch
cuz you know you know the time what time
is it you know what time it is
I don't know we're doing time for shadow
show that's the amendment are you gonna
do some like they were you whack me yeah
you rely on hat okay Oh what that means
yeah so anyway this is crazy on her
channel she does all the things I said
Lister mate - she said dude why won't
you give me a shout-out anything -
listen I should actually watch the
trailer for Logan's Run uh maybe maybe
we're talking about the remake
cuz if it's a remake I'll check that out
I'm for sure what that is Logan's Run of
course you don't know what it is you
don't know anything about Louise these
days gosh hey hey now hey hey I have
some stuff going on I can't know
everything about everything but I would
like to know these things
you see yeah I don't know how long as
runners either actually crap about it
all I know is that it's like a sci-fi
movie I know I just wanted to give you a
hard time
anyway Lister's mate - I like Lister's a
lot Lister's to me are an amazing
invention you know Thomas Edison
invented Lister's a familiar with what
society or definition is a Lister a
Lister is kind of like a bear trap but
they're actually designed for penguins
for when penguins because penguins are
known to possibly be the next dominant
animal in
evolution is so confident you think I
was about to look that up they believe
you know I don't know what Alice tourism
good definitional yeah
the man you vision you said give me a
shout out fine man you vision what does
that mean does he Manning of vision it
sounds like a television manual vision
like you view it manually what don't we
do that all the time let it all go so
let's you're tied down to like a KGB
chair then no it's not gonna happen cuz
they your eyes
they do yeah yeah anybody man you vision
I hope you don't work for the KGB but
you sound like a good guy man you vision
um you know what you are you're the god
of television that's who you are
yeah there's such a thing why what does
what powers does this person possess uh
this person is able to pretty much form
anything into a hologram that plays out
from his chest and it will it's like
r2d2 when you place messages for people
like Michael Jackson like Michael
Jackson headache any trailer you want so
you could do trailer reactions anywhere
cool mmm I think you should be on our
side you should be on our side yeah look
out Gator boy Tyler Giordano he wants a
shout-out and he said I'm awesome and he
also said never doubt your power of
awesome he's awesome right
also I saw you on It's Always Sunny he
caught my episode of It's Always Sunny
in Philadelphia I told people that I had
a line on an episode and some people
found it and Tyler is one of them
giordano he's Italian he big fat [ __ ]
bus Riga hmm I want to see it you do
yeah pull up on Netflix best line of the
whole show best line in the whole series
really Tyler is the name of Brad Pitt's
character in Fight Club giordano is a
and you must be a beautiful man if my
facts are me correctly about both of
those names and if you are ugly shame on
you and you should be banned like a
leper Macklin
I'm sorry only people just don't belong
in this world you're a horrible person
Hey don't hate the player hate the game
that's what I said okay I just happen to
be part of the extremely good-looking
Club Oh oh really yeah okay impossible
to resist Club Katya um hung like a
horse Club all right we're done we're
not done it's over we're not done stop
um Chitty Chitty Bang Bang Club I'm also
part of the Costco Club that's a good
Club to be in that's the best pub to be
a lot Sox tastes delicious you don't
even need a car to buy the hot
dog-eating yeah but when you go inside
to get all the little tasters you get
the tasters yeah damn hot dog from
Costco sounds really good no you turned
me on to Costco food it's like a problem
yeah we have it every time without
having sex he's meeting my family in a
week they watch all these videos good
then they should know that you have a
baby alone no hey why did you not pull
out why no stop Melissa I think you're
going too far haha go too far yeah
you're going to Ferrari too with your
reaction to my words okay just calm down
they're just words words that people may
believe words that people should believe
you
these are you should always believe
these words never believe you know trust
me and Paris sex is real crazy amounts
of sex crazy amounts orgies with all the
girls from the chain is imagination
imagination that's cool I don't know why
girls just wanted me that I bone all you
cuz you don't I do I love you look guys
this is a vine video and this is like a
15 minute video I'm gonna cut this now
yeah bye hop